this is tons you get from bond 24 years
old he's a modern young city dweller up
to now he hasn't owned a car conscious
is getting to school and back home by
bus and train was simple Pleasant and
inexpensive but now his media industry
internship requires him to show up at
various shooting locations with
substantial equipment public transport
just doesn't stop everywhere he needs to
go so what does he expect from a car but
conscience says a prime criterion is low
maintenance and operating costs of
course the initial price is important to
as a student on shoes wallet isn't fat
so he's thinking of a small city car
ciouds me has precisely this young
target group in mind in Germany the
five-door basic version starts at 9686
euros the model we're testing with style
equipment goes for about eleven thousand
euros time to bring tons you and the me
together
appearance matters well okay it's no
rolls-royce but the exterior looks good
enough for Tanja and the interior the
CEOs dashboard levers and buttons look
pretty good for a car in this class the
display on the sat-nav is tailored to a
modern young potential clientele
the compact earns points on comfort and
space as well the five-door vehicles
backseat is easily accessible so how
does the trunk rate well the young media
designer be able to stow his camera
equipment in it well packed his half
stored the backseat rest folds down
easily increasing the storage space to
up to 650 liters
the result Tanja says all he needs fits
in the trunk
so he's content time to experience the
me on the road we tested the most
powerful gasoline version it's one liter
engine generates 55 kilowatts
the Sapphire kanjou says he's pleased
with a say at meas handling the steering
is direct the gearshift well and so the
car is fun to drive the me we tested has
a top speed of 172 kilometers an hour
but it's not a fast starter accelerating
from zero to 100 takes all of thirteen
point two seconds so the car is
definitely conceived for in town driving
and there its maneuverability is
persuasive the meet has a manual five
gear transmission but it also comes in
an automatic version its start/stop
function is a plus two likes the good
overview the ciothes instrument panels
and big windows offer he also likes the
start/stop function because he wants to
consider fuel he does mention that his
fuel consumption is 5.7 liters per 100
kilometers Oh
the manufacturer claims it needs only
four point two liters of course other
makers fudge on fuel consumption - so
what's conscious overall impression he
says it has everything he needs he likes
it so well that public transportation
has lost a customer
you